ladies and gentlemen Snooki
your real name's Nicole but you don't go
by Nicole is your real name Steve-O some
people call me Steve I'm not particular
so where's the O Come From it just comes
from drunk people yelling at oh okay
yeah got it
Nookie you didn't have that name before
Jersey Shore yeah no so when we tried
out for the show we have to like fill
out this questionnaire and they wanted
everyone to have a nickname my only
girlfriend in high school her name's
Katie she's the only person that ever
called me Snooki and it's from Say the
Last Dance okay the DJ's name is Snooki
so I made out with a guy for the first
time out of my friends so she was like
you're snooking I'm like okay fine so
that's what I put in the application
it's good and now everyone calls me
snucky